today on the Matt Walsh show the country
is in flames and many in the media and
on the Left have insisted that we must
sympathize with the people who are
setting the fires but the attempt to
justify and romanticize looting and
arson is of course morally outrageous
and deranged and irrational insane many
of the words I could use to describe it
and I will use many of those words today
because I want to speak some plain
truths about this issue today there are
some things that need to be said and I'm
going to say them also 5 headlines
including celebrities helping to fund
and support the destruction of poor
minority neighborhoods this is the the
cause that celebrities are rallying
behind right now and finally I thought
that it was dangerous to protest during
a pandemic isn't that what we were told
for months I mean in the media spend
months telling us that if you go out and
protest during a pandemic you gonna kill
people gonna kill grandma that's what we
were told what happened all of that
we're gonna talk about all of that today
on the show I I do as I said have a lot
too a lot to say as you can imagine I
went away for less than a week I went
away for you know what like four days on
vacation the country erupted in the
meantime so I leave you people alone for
a few days and this is what you do
without my without my guidance so I'm
gonna try to say most of what I think
needs to be said today though of course
I'm sure I can't fit it all into one
show and we'll start here amid the media
fueled Democrat endorsed chaos that is
currently gripping our cities a lot of
effort has been made to justify and
romanticize the violent hordes that are
you're wreaking destruction all over the
place but despite these extremely
pathetic rationalizations the rioters
are not aggrieved citizens deeply
hurting and in pain and engaging in
serial arson and random assaults as some
sort of coping mechanism for the trauma
they've suffered or is some sort of
desperate plea for peace and justice
no on quite on the contrary they are
criminals and sociopaths and
setting stuff on fire because they think
it's fun and they're stealing shoes and
booze and electronics for the very
simple reason that they want shoes and
booze and electronics and it's free if
they go steal it and they have no moral
compunction about doing so that's it
okay how do I know this well for one
thing I've seen the footage as we all
have you know go go go watch the footage
of these people doing these things
they're smiling and laughing with glee
as they commit these atrocities okay
these are not the faces of oppressed
people these are the faces of bullies
who delight in the suffering of
strangers now here's here's just as an
example I'll play this for you here's
someone walking out of a looted
Cheesecake Factory with a cheesecake
they stole now we can't see the
expression on their face there because
they're wearing a mask but what do you
think do you think that person is
weeping onto the mask you think they're
weeping as they walk out with the
cheesecake
were they looting that cheesecake out of
grief no listen the point isn't the pain
that these crooks are supposedly in it's
the pain that they enjoy inflicting on
others what we're watching are a bunch
of people who enjoy causing suffering
and so that's what they're doing
speaking of which I want to play just a
few other clips of different examples
around the country yesterday and I could
spend five hours playing clips like this
as you well know but because there's a
lot more where this came from but you
need to see I think if you have you
haven't seen some of this stuff you need
to see in someone to play some of it
it's not easy to watch but we need to
see it so first here's a truck driver
being pulled out of his truck and beaten
by a mob of many dozens of people watch
[Music]
[Applause]
now don't worry don't worry an arrest
has been made because of that incident
don't worry about that they've made
arrests the police are on the case
they've arrested the driver the driver
was arrested the guy that was pulled out
of his truck and beaten he was arrested
and he was right he's arrested because
he drove into a crowd the claim from the
media and the left and the police is
that he was trying to I guess kill
protesters by driving into a crowd but
what they failed to mention is that the
protesters were on the interstate and
this guy is just trying to get through
if he was trying to kill protesters then
why did he stop his truck putting his
own life at risk
rather than plowing through them he
stopped this truck I mean if the point
was to plow through them then why didn't
he plow through them now look at the the
aerial footage of the whole incident and
I'll just just watch this for a second
okay so yes he's coming through there
why is he coming to it because it's a
highway alright and he's in a truck but
he's why does he stop if if the claim is
that he deserved to be pulled out of his
truck and beaten because he was trying
to kill me why did he stop if he if
that's what he was trying to do he would
has he would have plowed right he didn't
he stopped because he didn't want to
kill anybody didn't want to hurt anybody
that's the only logical conclusion here
and for his trouble he was pulled out
and beaten this so so the claim that
we're hearing is that protestors
quote-unquote protestors have the right
to shut down whatever highway they want
to and if you have the audacity to drive
through it you know to treat it like a
highway they have every right to beat
you unconscious that's the claim that
we're being not just by the media that's
basically what the police are telling us
apparently now we've got a lot more to
play some other clips as well but before
we do that I want to tell you about
LifeLock you know the LifeLock is all
about security a different kind of
security but but security is what we
need right now and the thing about you
know being on the Internet is are all
kinds of internet scams I think we've
all come close at least to being duped a
time or two by internet Scouts because
they're getting very clever with
with with how they go about this for
example a hacker group called shiny
hunters claims to have breached 10
companies and is now selling their user
databases on a dark web marketplace for
illegal illegal products the companies
range from an online dating app to a
food delivery service to online stores
and newspapers the listed database holds
73 million user records which are being
sold for around eighteen thousand
dollars so this is the kind of stuff
that that's out there and if you don't
have life lock it would be very
difficult for you to protect yourself
against it every day we put our
information at risk on the internet and
cyber criminals around the world keep
finding new ways to steal identities
LifeLock is a leader in identity theft
protection and that's why you need them
because they've been doing this for a
long time they know how to do it they
could do it a lot better than you know I
can just on my own if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised
they will send you an alert they detect
a wide range of identity threat identity
threats out there and there are a wide
range of them no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but life
lock can see threats that you might miss
on your own so join now and save up to
25% off your first year go to life lock
calm slash Walsh that's life lock calm
slash walls to save twenty five percent
off okay so we saw the truck driver now
let's here's this is in Santa Monica
speaking of trucks being attacked this
is an Amazon truck being looted in Santa
Monica so you see they're just carrying
the packages off there again grieving
this is all part of the grieving process
folks is that they're just there in the
morning who among us who among us hasn't
hasn't gone through who among us hasn't
in in in a in an act of grief as a
coping mechanism stopped an Amazon truck
and carried a package off right haven't
we all done that here's a man being
beaten by mob after he steps in to
protect the woman who was pushed off a
bike I'm gonna pause for a second and
let you watch this
[Music]
now if you're ready for the worst one of
all and it does get worse here's a mob
vandalizing a store the female store
owner comes out confronts them very bold
on her part and they proceeded to
assault her with a 2x4
[Music]
okay so again I ask the question what do
you think you're seeing here people who
are in pain people who are hurting
people who want justice for George Floyd
please shut up with that just just shut
up and you know what even if they are in
pain I don't care I don't care how they
feel I don't care what they've
experienced I don't care I don't care I
don't care about any oppression they
have in their minds or in reality
suffered I don't care and I'll tell you
why the moment you set a building on
fire
the moment you assault a woman with a
with a with a with a 2x4 okay the moment
you victimized the innocent your
feelings don't matter nothing matters
you are a victimizer not a victim if you
want your feelings and your experiences
to matter to to the average citizen then
you don't do that and you don't set
entire cities on fire
pretty simple when you start doing that
you are the bad guy now you are part of
the problem and I'm not gonna sit down
and say why did you set why did you set
that building on fire please talk to me
to share your feelings I want to hear
why did you do that I just know I'm not
judging I'm not judging just just to
just share all your inner experiences
and maybe we know you're a scumbag
you're a villain you're a bully you're a
terrorist
now we have to understand something
about basic human psychology okay a
human doesn't think to himself well the
police are racist therefore I must run
into this burnt-out target and steal a
pile of genes that's that's not a
calculation that anybody makes no a
human would think to himself a bad human
would think thumbs up I have an
opportunity to run into his burned-out
target and steal pile of genes because
other people are doing it and so I'm
going to do that I have the opportunity
so I'm going to do it now the ladder is
a coherent calculation unlike the former
which is just a non sequitur
but it's the calculation of a criminal
not a victim now you might say isn't it
a simplification on the other extreme is
it you know there's there's a
simplification on the on the one extreme
of saying that all these rioters and
vandals and looters are a bunch of you
know aggrieved sufferers and mourners
right that's that's that's an absurd
simplification but am I not engaging in
my own simplification by writing them
all off as a bunch of nihilistic
hoodlums now I don't think so I don't
think I am
because arbitrary destruction is the
very Hall mark of nihilistic hoodlum ISM
it's exactly what you would expect to
see now and I use words like arbitrary
and random you know these are the words
that I'm that I'm using but of course we
realized that that description only
applies to the behavior of the grinning
masses of people who can't believe their
luck that their local government has
decided to step aside and let them steal
and burn stuff at will that you know the
government and many of Minneapolis would
literally retreat and let them burn a
police station to the ground but so
there's that and we also recognize
though that at the center of this swarm
are domestic terrorist groups like an
Tifa and they're wealthy sponsors who
are acting in a way that is anything but
arbitrary okay they have specific
political and ideological ends that they
hope to achieve and they are using the
so called protesters and their pension
for arson as a means to that end so
that's what we're dealing with here
we're dealing with a core of domestic
terrorists surrounded by
and exploiting thieves arsonists and
thugs of various other types that's
that's the that's the way it all breaks
down a lot more to say about this in
just a second
but now our good friends of course at
rock out a long time supporters of this
show who we really appreciate along with
all of our sponsors by the way who you
know during this very difficult time
over the last several months you know we
really appreciate all of our sponsors
who have supported this show and and
everyone at The Daily wire and we also
appreciate you guys for supporting the
show and for listening to us talk about
our sponsors and their great products
and you know if you if you hear us talk
about something and it's something you
think you need then really consider
supporting these sponsors we would
appreciate that now you know if you need
auto parts if you need car parts I think
the most reasonable thing to do the
easiest and most convenient thing to do
is to look online you know rather than
trying to go into a chain store deal
with all that rockauto.com is so much
easier than walking into a store and
having to answer all the questions and
and all of that stuff and also knowing
that they're probably not going to have
what you're looking for they got to look
it up online themselves and just order
it you could have done that yourself
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
price as possible rather than changing
their prices based on what the market
will bear they're not gonna try to just
build you for all you're worth they're
gonna just offer a low the lowest price
they can a fair price and you know that
you could be confident that when you go
to rockauto.com it's a family business
you know they've been serving customers
for over 20 years
rockauto.com is the place to go for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low
that's that's what it comes down to it's
the convenience and it's low prices so
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that we sent you
okay now we talked about all this and
I'm pretty harsh in the way that I talk
about these protesters it's true that
not every protester quote-unquote is
burning buildings and looting
in fact some of the protesters may
actually be doing something that sort of
approximates actual protesting believe
it or not you know but if the thing is
that that's such a shock to see at this
point that when you go online you see
people sharing videos of well look at
these protesters in this inspiring here
are some protesters who aren't setting
things on fire who in fact here are some
protesters trying to stop other protests
or some setting stuff on fire yeah I
mean good for them I appreciate that but
but that's that's that's what we expect
people to do that's a I don't give you a
lot of credit for that the fact that
it's that it's notable when we find
protesters not setting stuff on fire
that's a problem now if you if you
here's the thing if you join the protest
you are knowingly joining a mob that
includes a significant portion of
rioters and looters and terrorists you
are literally providing cover for these
elements and metaphorically maybe also
literally clasping your hands with them
in solidarity you deserve to be lumped
in with them because you have lumped
yourself in with them so that's why I'm
not interested in this you know
separating was the good protesters from
the bad ones know I think they deserve
to all be lumped in together to be
honest with you I want you to consider
this okay with the people who are
currently arguing that protesters and
looters are two separate groups and that
the former shouldn't be lumped in with
the latter would they still be making
that argument if a bunch of abortion
clinics were burned to the ground during
a pro-life demonstration I mean imagine
a pro-life demonstrate know this but
this would never happen
okay but it just doesn't happen to
pro-life demonstrate I've been to many
there there have been many pro-life
demonstrations there didn't paralyze
demonstrations every week in this
country somewhere every day practically
the March for life means going on has
been going on for over forty years
hundreds of thousands coming to DC for
that you never see anything like this
ever but just imagine if there was a
pro-life demonstration and a sizeable
Porsche
of that crowd was setting abortion
clinics on fire and assaulting you know
Planned Parenthood workers and that sort
of thing do you think any of the people
saying well don't lump them in together
you think they'd be saying that in that
case or maybe this is a better example
what if there was a resurgence of the
Tea Party but imagine there's a
resurgence of the Tea Party but at every
Tea Party rally
large groups of avowed white
supremacists showed up and had a funny
habit of you know assaulting bystanders
ransacking stores setting police
stations on fire imagine this happening
the Tea Party rallies across the the
country and at every single one without
fail
you've got rioting and looting is there
any doubt that the entire Tea Party
movement and everyone who attended one
of its demonstrations would be cast in
the same light as that not the Nazi
looters in fact that happened with the
original Tea Party we're not the
original but the the 2008 version that
happened with that Tea Party even though
there weren't any Nazi looters they were
still accused of doing it now imagine if
there actually were Nazi looters what
would happen then what would people be
saying about them what would the media
be saying about them and the thing is as
somebody who supported the Tea Party the
first time around I would also be
casting them in that light if I looked
at this resurgent Tea Party and I saw
that every single time you have this
sizable portion of actual Nazis or
burning stuff I would look at that and I
would say you know what there's there's
something really wrong here
with not just with those people but with
the whole movement and I don't want to
be affiliated with it I'm not gonna show
up to one of these things because it
just wouldn't be credible to claim that
the Nazi looting which happens every
time is some sort of coincidental
aberration
now perhaps I'm wrong you know maybe the
the good ones are entirely distinct from
the bad ones and the former are
benevolent in their motives and methods
and I unfairly maligned them by
characterizing the whole movement or
whatever it is this way maybe so
that's a risk on
to take because we are much better off
condemning this mob to strongly than not
strongly enough I'm gonna err on that
side I'm gonna err on the side of being
too strong in my condemnation most
people even the critics of these
so-called protests have erred on the
side of kindness to the mob and
understanding and tolerance which is why
most criticisms of all of this are
couched in a series of disclaimers and
qualifications about the profound
legitimacy of their grievances and the
great importance of the conversation
they're allegedly trying to have with us
so you hear a lot of you know now the
people who set AutoZone on fire for no
apparent reason they're right to be
upset and their feelings are so
important to me so important and I very
much share their concerns and I'm sure
that they're all wonderful people and I
just they're very very good and by the
way can I just say I find them
strikingly good-looking but with that
said by the time you get to the point
you've already lost the point just cut
to the chase cut that crap out you don't
even believe it anyway so shut up with
that just get to the point of condemning
the destruction of our cities that's
happening right now get to that point we
don't need the rest of it we don't need
the rest of I'm sure some of them are so
good and it's that we don't need that
part of it because our cities continue
to burn while we play footsie with the
people who are holding the matches I
think what we need now is to speak
plainly and to respond boldly to what
we're seeing alright let's move on to
our five end lines although it's all
kind of one headline jumbled together
but we'll sort through this
let's start by zeroing in number one on
what happened in our nation's capital
last night The Daily wire has the report
it says dozens of Secret Service agents
were reportedly injured by violent
rioters near the White House as the
rioters threw objects and burned
American flags late on Sunday evening
which occurred at the Lincoln Memorial
after the mallika memorial was
vandalized hours earlier a Fox News
Editor Greg ray reported more than 50
Secret Service agents were
fire set by rioters blaze near the White
House and authorities were searching for
car bombs late Sunday has protests over
the death of George Floyd continued to
roil the Capitol just two days after
President Trump had to be taken to a
bunker for his safety and here's a look
but here's a live video by the way of
the flag being ripped down and burned
take a look at this
okay so they're burning churches the
flags are attacking law enforcement in
DC right outside the White House and
still we have not seen mass arrests
still somehow we haven't seen dozens of
people handcuffed and carted away in
buses still we have not seen that this
is the dissolution of our society
unfolding before our eyes okay we are
watching it in real time this is not the
beginning of it it didn't start this
past week I think I fear this is the
conclusion the culmination the final
stroll the final break is what we're
watching happening right now number two
over the weekend Justin Timberlake
joined the group of celebrities who have
offered to support the riots by bailing
out rioters he said please join me in
supporting the Minneapolis protesters by
donating to the MN freedom fund the
Minnesota free to fund the freedom fund
is combating the harms of incarceration
by plant by paying bail for low-income
individuals who cannot of otherwise
afford it so if they if they you know
are rioting and destroying stuff Justin
Timberlake is gonna make sure he gets
them out of jail put some bad back on
the streets so they could get back to it
he's gonna Justin Timberlake is gonna
make sure of that isn't this so kind of
our celebrities you know they sit safely
in their mansions protected by gates and
fences and security systems and armed
guards and they they generously offer to
support and fund the people who are
burning down poor neighborhoods very
very what absolute philanthropists these
people are they are donating to the
cause of destroying poor minority
communities that's what they're doing in
fact when you see celebrities offering
to bail out rioters remember that they
are on the they're on the side of the
people who reduced this woman to tears
and despair and for good reason watch
because the buses aren't running these
people did this for no reason is that
gonna bring your honor back here yours
is in a better place that we are land
last night I will be honest I wish
I was worried yours was because this is
ridiculous these people are lovely so if
you side with the rioters you side
against her you're on the opposite side
of her you're with the people who did
this to her number three and here's a
tweet from sister Bethany in Chicago
their bookstore
the nuns book store was broken into
looted the looters stole their books so
they're they're stealing books from nuns
is what they're doing this is just
cartoonish evil at this point they
they're like if you were to write a
fiction story where the antagonists are
rioters and looters that's that's what
these people would be that's how
absurdly over-the-top villainous they
are for on the theme here of you know
highlighting the true victims here's a
report out of Rochester featuring a
minority business owner whose business
was destroyed by looters looters who are
supposedly concerned about racism
against minorities but this is what they
did to him watch everything vote this
one don't tell all the hairy ass guy
that had inside of 1500 Abdullah Saleh
has never seen anything like it in his
20 years in business everything this is
almost empty stuff that wasn't theirs
that looters stole early Saturday
evening I see a lot of cut head and
somebody broke the door and everybody
come to insite Saleh was cleaning his
place across the street this is what it
looked like outside Hudson Avenue
Walmart it's sad and it's disappointing
these two from Irondequoit had hoped to
shop here there was a heavy police
presence after reports of looting both
ladies lamented the police killing of a
man in Minneapolis and the unrest that's
followed I feel like we're trying to get
justice for something but
it's not helping us because all its
gonna do is make them target us more
with George Floyd you know but our
officers are supposed to serve to
protect us and keep us safe and yet
we're getting the complete opposite
we're feeling unsafe and unprotected
back across the street what hurts la the
most is he knows many of the looters and
I got no problem nobody in this crazy
I'm sure he'll clean up so he can open
up again there's one in McLennan and I
want to support my kids as long do the
right thing this one in Irondequoit and
his crazy you know Seth Voorhees
spectrum News number five I think maybe
we could all use a pick-me-up after all
this a lot of lot of very gloomy dreary
stuff inevitably but something a little
bit more cheerful something to brighten
our spirits and give us hope for
tomorrow because I still believe in that
I'm still at heart I'm still an optimist
and so on that note something positive
something you know kind of fun for the
whole family
here's a rioter trying to set a fire and
instead setting himself on fire watch
[Music]
[Applause]
so there you go there is a God after all
that's just any what can you say that's
that's hard to generate much much
sympathy I suppose but but the media
would can I mean the media finds away
many of the people in the media they
find a way to to sympathize with and
feel sorry for somebody like that now
let's move on to our daily cancellation
in fact before we do that though I want
to tell you about our leftist tears
tumblers I don't know if we've if you've
ever heard us mention these things
before you probably haven't we don't
talk about it much but these things just
I mean what can I say about them they
are my whole purpose for living at this
point it's just for my tears my left
just here I wake up in the morning I
think there's no point to life but at
least I can drink out of this tumbler
and that's what keeps me going every
single day now normally as you know I
generally am NOT a fan of joy or
happiness but this brings me joy and
this is what will bring you joy the
double tumbler deal is back but it's
only available for our most exclusive
membership to your all access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership all access members
get to participate in all access live
our brand-new interactive programming
feature one of us daily wire hosts you
know hang out every night at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific and we just hang
out we have a conversation it's a lot of
fun all access memberships now also
include two of the irreplaceable leftist
tears tumblers the tumblers are
literally overflowing with tears at the
thought of this offer guys that's what
it comes down to finally all access
members also get the benefits of our
other membership tiers including an
ad-free website experience access to our
live broadcasts and show library access
to the shows mail bags and the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show you
get all of that you
ask for more you better not ask for more
you greedy sob s so head over to the
deli wire comm today Lee Weyer comm site
subscribe to join all access and get 50%
off with coupon code Walsh right now
that's daily wire.com slash subscribe
see you there
okay for so far daily cancellation we
are once again canceling the kovat 19
chicken littles who we've cancelled many
times on the show but this time a little
bit different we're not canceling them
because they're running around screaming
that the sky is falling
instead we're canceling them because
they're not because they stopped doing
it over the last few days they stopped
running around and screaming they
stopped very suddenly and very
conspicuously and I don't think it's
because they came to their senses
if that's if that was the reason then
the last thing that we do is cancel them
in fact if you're old enough to remember
the bygone days of three weeks ago or
even like two weeks ago then maybe you
could just join me for a second on a
trip down memory lane because back in
those bad old times the news media were
quite certain that it was brazen and
irresponsible and possibly murderous
even to protest during a pandemic you're
gonna kill grandma if you do it that's
what we were told now not to harp on
this Antion history but I can recall for
example this article from Vox assuring
me that protesting under these
conditions is racist because it might
kill black people then there was the
article on Penn Live which has repeated
the the once common argument that
protesters shouldn't receive medical
care if they get kovin 19 because
they're being so reckless and
irresponsible
The Guardian warned that protesters
might be spreading the virus quote far
and wide Jimmy Kimmel among others said
that protestors are quote suicidal dr.
Burks called it quote devastatingly
worrisome that protesters would gather
in the middle of an outbreak and you
know risk spreading it there are other
people who call the protesters reckless
and mind-bogglingly selfish The
Washington Post
assured us that demonstrators quote
don't care about lives and Slate accuse
them of quote twisting the idea of
Liberty another
Washington Post op-ed compared
protestors to typhoid mary the week in
the nation both agreed that it's it's
dangerous to be out rallying at a time
like this
USA Today was even more direct they said
that protesters are quote risking your
health these are just a few examples
many more could be offered but what's
the use because we all lived through the
past three months
when Cova 19 was the only thing the
media cared about and any gathering of
people of any size in any context for
any reason was condemned as a heedless
and foolhardy exercise in virus
transmission even people who simply have
you forget about protests like even
people who simply went to the beach to
sunbathe and and wade in the water were
blasted in panicky news headlines like
like this one from CBS and I'm talking
about this as if we need to be reminded
when I went away for a vacation that's
what they were saying I come back and
all of a sudden it's like Cova 19 went
away it's gone what a miracle now it's
no use arguing that protests the the
quote-unquote protests that are
currently ravaging our cities are more
important and more justified when I
brought up this point online that was
the response they said well this is
different because this this this protest
is so much more important and so that's
why it's they're allowed to do it and
they're not going to be criticized now I
hardly see mass looting as a more worthy
cause than standing up against draconian
and disastrous and unconstitutional
lockdowns that decimated the economy and
shredded the Bill of Rights but that's
beside the point the point is that the
very act of protesting or of forming
large groups for any other reason was to
was supposed to put many lives at risk
and thus was worthy of condemnation and
prohibition by the government and in one
fell swoop literally overnight all of
that was put to the side Ted just it
just it's like a not even like never
happened why has koban 19 gone away did
its method of transmission suddenly
change are we I mean did it turn into an
exclusively like sex
we transmitted disease or something all
of a sudden I don't understand you you
said forget it but it doesn't matter
what the cause is let's just say for the
sake of argument that these protesters
are righteous in their cause and it's
such an important cause and then bla bla
bla all the rest of it okay fine but
there's still what they're killing each
other right there killing grandma isn't
that a problem I mean shouldn't we be
talking about that shouldn't the media
be mentioning it if you care about these
protesters and you're I mean aren't you
if you believe that protesting or a
pandemic is gonna kill people including
the protesters themselves then if you
care about these protesters wouldn't you
be saying hey go home don't do this or
again maybe there was a miracle maybe
Cova 19 went away miraculously or maybe
on the other hand the media just decided
to dump one narrative in favor of
another for political reasons I think
that the answer is is of course very
clear and the lesson that we should all
take um is also clear that if you want
to protest during a pandemic you should
do it safely and responsibly by burning
down buildings stopping traffic and
beating random bystanders apparently
that is the only way that you'll escape
criticism if you protest during your
pandemic not just escape criticism but
also escape prosecution I mean it's it's
well you know another way of putting
this is you can't go to a church inside
you can burn one to the ground though
that's gonna be a lot safer than
actually attending the church all right
now one last thing and one other thing I
wanted to say in lieu of emails today I
want to close with a thought another
thought not a very encouraging one
unfortunately maybe more of a question
though I guess and the question is this
what we should be asking ourselves is
where do we go from here right
eventually the riots will burn
themselves out literally they're gonna
have to because it's apparent that our
leaders in Washington and in the states
and cities around the country have
abandoned their post and abandoned us us
and we'll do nothing so that that much
is clear they're just not gonna do
anything so this is gonna run its course
and whatever damage to property and
lives that will be done will be done and
that's all there is to it when it ends
though what then what's next I mean do
we start working towards unity again
well unity around what I mean the
reality is there are many and this will
not change even when the riots stop this
won't change that there are many people
in this country who have no problem
setting fires stealing stuff and
attacking the innocent it's happening
all over this is not isolated it's not
fringe but even more concerning is that
there are many more people who agree
with those methods who defend them who
justify them so I ask you what unity can
you have with people like that
what are you unifying around okay the
people who are throwing bricks and
setting fires and then the other people
who are justifying that you want me to
unify with them based on what I mean
just it's if there's got to be some some
unifying principle now if they suddenly
and miraculously change and repent and
experience a massive shift in attitude
and priority then okay then unity will
be pretty easy but if they remain them
and you remain you
how do you unify and I've been making
this point for years you probably heard
me have you've probably heard me say it
before there's just now an added urgency
to it I think because it sounds great
and it feels good to talk about unity to
call for it to advocate it and all of
that but you have to unify around
something there has to be some
underlying and significant commonality
for there to be unity for there to be a
country at all a real country
a real people a real society a real
culture in that commonality cannot just
be that we all happen to exist within
the same borders especially when our
borders are so porous as they are and
they they hardly even exist now it has
to be something realer and deeper than
that
now here here would be a here would be a
good unifying principle shared
fundamental values and priorities okay
there's something you can unify around
maybe you disagree about a whole lot you
come from different backgrounds
different races nations creeds and
everything but you have these very
fundamental values and priorities and at
least you have that and you can unify
around that and that would be something
very real I mean you could have a real
country that way but we don't have that
we don't even come close to having that
we don't even I mean we don't even have
a shared language or a shared many
shared traditions or anything we share
nothing in this country anymore and that
more than anything is why we're seeing
what we're seeing and why we've seen so
much of what we've seen over the last
not just the last week of the last few
years or the last few decades
there is no unifying principle we as a
people have nothing in common there are
pockets of people who you know in their
own ideological tribes who have things
in common but as a P as a as a as a
nation nothing you know I believe that
the LAT probably
in my lifetime it's sad as it is to
think and to say the last moment of real
unity was right after 9/11 that's why
it's been 20 years and people still talk
about that I think how sad and pathetic
that is in 20 years later and people
like myself are still so I remember
right after 9/11 and people were unified
and it didn't even last very long was a
couple of weeks maybe from what I can
recall but there was a couple of weeks
maybe a little bit longer where
everybody seemed to basically be on the
same page and we were sharing something
we were sharing grief and we you know
wanted to get the guys who did it and
and you know we had that that was the
last time and even tragedies now and if
there was another 9/11 I don't think
there would be the same effect I think
it would be from the very first instant
politicized tribe alized I don't have
the answer this is just a question
something we need to start thinking
about you know we may come to a point
where there are some very hard realities
that we just have to face and maybe one
of those realities is that we just can't
be one country
we just can't we're not we can't I mean
if you're someone who would justify what
we're seeing happening right now and
would promote it I mean not to mention
if you're in that camp you're probably
also in the camp of thinking that babies
aren't people you know 60 million dead
babies is something to celebrate and not
to mention you also probably think that
you know like the categories of men and
women don't exist my point is you're
just somebody in a whole different
forget about a different country you're
in a different universe for me I don't
even know what universe you're in I
don't know what reality you're in you
might as well be an alien from a
different galaxy that's how different
you are from me and how little I have in
common with you
and frankly if I could live on a
different planet from you I would
and that is the cheerful note that I
think we will leave things on today
sorry I couldn't be more positive right
after vacation but hey I did have a big
big good vacation anyway and I caught a
five pound bass so that would be my
positive note for the fruit today stay
safe out there everybody
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire twenty20 race riots looting Orson
black lives matter and Tifa all sorts of
mayhem overtaking cities coast to coast
this weekend spreading misery and chaos
but on the bright side since no one
cares about social distancing anymore
the unrest seems to have cured
coronavirus then the mainstream media
recast black lives matter and
anti-matter kists as white supremacists
which put white liberals in a tough spot
since they were all raising money to
bail out the alleged white supremacists
from jail a lot to get to check it out
on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]